how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe which looks like
is going to be a lot bigger come
marvel's phase 4.
with all of the talks rumors and reports
that spider-man 3 is going to be a
multiverse movie and that we're going to
get different versions of spider-man
we now have another interesting fact
about spider-man and
all of the other different iterations of
spider-man that makes this multiverse
even more
interesting and this is coming from an
actual mcu director
as well so we'll break it down but first
big congratulations to youtube user
aaron campout for being the winner of
the zombie hulk funko pop and for this
week we're going to be giving away a
black widow funko pop from the avengers
game
and a big thank you to heroes
hideout.com for providing these funkos
if you need some gift ideas for the
holidays they have tons of marvel
merchandise
now for those of you who have twitter
you may have saw this recently but
duncan jones tweeted out this tangential
connections through portals is covered
under the doctor strange
subsection then he asked scott
derrickson can i have a ruling
scott derrickson of course directed the
first doctor strange film in the marvel
cinematic universe and he was supposed
to direct the second one
but things didn't work out there because
from what i believe they called
differences so now we have sam raimi who
directed the original spider-man trilogy
which says something of itself about the
next doctor strange film but scott
derrickson
did reply and this was his response all
spider-man
iterations are de facto mcu meaning
are in fact in the marvel cinematic
universe and this is a
very interesting statement especially
when you consider the fact that it's
coming from scott derrickson who
directed the first doctor strange film
and since he was going to direct the
second doctor strange film he would
definitely know if
these different iterations of spider-man
were in fact going to come into our main
marvel cinematic universe because after
spider-man 3
comes doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness so he would have been
informed and filled in on whatever is
supposed to happen
in spider-man 3. so this seems like it
could mean two different things
and the first one could be that he is
simply just stating that all of the
other spider-man films that have been
around
are part of the mcu because doctor
strange does have the ability to travel
through the multiverse he can open up a
portal and go straight into the sam
raimi spider-man universe into the
amazing spider-man universe
heck he could even go into the japanese
spider-man universe and the fact that
doctor strange has this power
and america chavez as well who was
supposed to be coming in doctor strange
too
the fact that they have these powers
could simply make all of the spider-man
part of the
larger marvel cinematic universe which
is the multiverse where everything
connects
and this is absolutely a possibility of
how we could see these different
iterations of the spider-man
we know doctor strange is going to be in
spider-man 3. he could perhaps open
portals and we could see the cameos from
toby maguire from andrew garfield as
they're looking into
other worlds other dimensions other
realities but that would mean that these
different iterations of spider-man
wouldn't really have a very prominent
role
but the second option is that scott
derrickson who was supposed to direct
doctor strange 2
knows what's going to happen in
spider-man 3. knows that a bunch of
other different spider-man are about to
end up in the film so because he knows
this
he's simply stating that yes all of
these other different iterations of
spider-man
are a part of the mcu because he knows
that they're about to head into
the mcu now there is a third and i'll
call it a bonus option that i don't
really believe
and i'll have to do a little bit more
research and theorize on this but
he could be meaning that the sam raimi
spider-man films and the amazing
spider-man films actually are
already within the mcu it's an
interesting thought
but the merit for it isn't exactly all
of there due to harry osborns and such
things like
that but if this were somehow true that
would mean that tom holland's peter
parker
wasn't the first spider-man in our
universe that would mean that andrew
garfield spider-man wasn't the first
spider-man but in fact toby maguire
spider-man was the first one and
if they did decide to go down this route
and kind of
retcon the mcu in a way that could mean
that toby maguire spider-man might not
even be the first one as well
i don't think they could pull this off
without changing some things that have
happened in the past which you can't
really do
that would mean that our mcu at some
point in time probably in avengers
in-game was altered in some different
way and that would mean that we're not
the main timeline anymore
so that's very unlikely but still given
the fact of what scott derrickson said
is definitely an option that's on the
table if marvel decided to retcon a few
things that were a part of the mcu
but let me know what you think scott
derrickson means when he said that
all spider-man's are in fact a part of
the mcu
do you think it's because of doctor
strange's ability to travel between
universes or do you think it's due to
the fact that we might be seeing these
other spider-man appear in spider-man 3.
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof